hey everyone its Johanna here to get you
ready for summer we will be drenched in
sweat
with today's body weight high-intensity
cardio exercises no equipment needed
only your strength and motivation and of
course a bottle of water and towel each
set will only last four minutes long
with a total of eight rounds each round
will consist of 20 seconds exercise with
10 seconds rest after we have completed
the first set you will get a full
one-minute break before moving on to the
second set do a total of 4 sets for a
quick and intense total body fat burning
workouts in under 20 minutes and I
promise you your heart will be pumping
and you will be burning lots of calories
remember to start with a quick 5 to 10
minutes warm-up to get your muscles
ready I am nervous but let's start
once you have done your warmup let's do
this together it's going to be
challenging so giving your all okay I'm
going to set my timer and let's start
with the first exercise which is jumping
jacks total body let's get on 20 seconds
each okay
I don't think I'll be talking here that
monitor throughout the workout keep
going okay nice and white beginners if
you find this physical you can just step
side to side okay ten seconds rest good
second workout kangaroo jumps okay so
what I wanted to do is to get down into
a white squat and jump forward touch the
ground jump back touch and jump forward
okay just like a kangaroo
nice get very good so make sure you're
powering up with your thighs filling
with eyes working and squat all the way
down
very good rest next workout mud jump
again stand in a wife start catch your
breath
let's get my jump ring milega Joma
hi okay that's it so go ahead and bring
your knees up beginners you can just
step and bring your legs up with other
jobs
enjoy very nice
keep going rest and fall to work out
side to side shuffles okay stop with one
side tie to the floor and you shuffle
and touch the floor okay keep your toes
pointed to the side again beginners just
take one step at a time
very good keep going
rest now we want to repeat the full
exercises again jumping jacks catch your
breath
let's go good show an intense keep going
with in through your nose and out
through a month get rest
second workout kangaroo jumps okay ready
get into a white spot jump forward let's
get jump forward just like a kangaroo
back forth and back make sure you're
going deep squat deep open up your chest
move forward
keep your body upright good keep going
one more good rest mud jumps okay nice
one up let's get up jump what steps you
what Wow very nice
keep going
few more rest last workout sighs sighs
chuckles okay done with one side
opposite side and let's go shuffle to
the side make sure you are going down to
the ground keep your chest up right
open it just look forward good feel the
Chicopee bum working very good
no just catch your breath that is the
end of the first set and now you get a
full 1 minute
brick so drink your water wipe your
sweat and if you have a mat take it out
here we are moving in to the second fat
ten more seconds Russ the second set we
will be incorporating a lot more arms
and as a core workouts okay
first look out psychologist to Bruce
let's go car your side up and up into a
purpose down right conscience get and
jump very good out
crunch crunch up jump nice
keep going one more rest
ten seconds rest second exercise
mountain climber let's get back down
onto the floor okay keep your body
straight and just climb okay
remember to take it at your own pace
beginners you can slow it down those of
you who are more advanced bring the
speed up good keep going bring it all
the way in
very nice rest third workout Oh Jack
planks step into a plank position
Oh B legs and jump in and out good so
you should really your shoulders and
your arms working at the same time keep
going
good job keep pushing
rest and the final workout did kick get
into this musician leave your body up
and just alternate with your legs so
giddy up
change legs good so really kick it as
high as you can and feel light as you
reach through your arms working as well
keep going doing it and rest
repeating the entire exercise again side
crunches - burpees let's go one two
Oh piss off good job beginners take a
step okay
ah but high five punch in good come on
guys
one more
very nice second exercise down on the
floor into mountain climbers I am
absolutely fine let's go keep going
mountain climbers you're doing it guys
we pushing
that's be more rest
Jack legs let's go love to exercises
let's go good
flank it out check it in very nice
ok why does he care and close it good
keep going guys you are rest the other
side then okay yeah right alternate legs
let's go kick okay really push it is
this enough workout for and then tell
you the rest
keep kicking hello tiny your ass keep
going guys last few more oh my god rest
10 seconds rest
and now you've got another phone one
minute rest grab your water drink your
water while your sweat and I want you to
be playing this video and do the third
and fourth set together with me it is
too short and intense so push it all
give it your own bring your heart rate
up and trust me you will see results you
will lose fat burn fat and lean up all
the rest for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you